my friend John paid some Pirates to go
to an island to talk to people about
Jesus when he knew that he had no
business doing
[Music]
that John's parents brought him up to be
Christian he was just like full of light
I had a little bit of a crush on him you
couldn't have asked for a better young
man he reminds me of who I wanted to
serve with he told me his plan was to go
live in the middle of the
Jungle it didn't sound that
bad I
thought that John would get
accepted people whose language no one
speaks whose culture no one
knows there's a fine line between faith
and
Madness once he found out about that
tribe he knew he was going to go all in
John was telling his story I'm a climber
I'm an adventurer here we are hiking out
if things don't go well you want it to
look like a young arrogant Western
person did a stupid thing and move
on John said to me this is what the plan
looks like happen right
here there's so many ways the seductions
of this story can go wrong this idea of
people who exist out of time that erases
their Humanity these cultures that are
isolated when we cross that boundary
we're saying your prohibition means
nothing to us that there's a group that
we would decide sorry you don't get to
hear about Jesus that's a violation of
their human right John did exactly what
Jesus told him to do John was pursuing a
fantasy in Discerning the
call and we can mess it
up my friend did something stupid and
courageous and bold and I wish I was
that
bold
[Music]